welcome to the marble panel you've
waited all day coming on eyes on here
does a lot of things can be very excited
to see I'm very excited to show these
things to you so now let's bring to the
stage the guy who is the Dreamweaver
hall but please welcome Kevin Feige oh
my god hi like it just gets here faster
and faster every day we were just here
last year it was really well we've had a
few movies since we had a movie called
dr. strange come out Gardens the galaxy
vol 2 and if you had a chance a couple
weeks away movie called spider-man
homecoming this so as we the MN team not
here they're in Atlanta they wanted to
put them together for you and now we
shall apply for as Janet Van Dyne
she was our shoes our dreams choice we
make in the first film and it's crazy
that she's that she's in it there are
few other casting announcements that I
want to mention to you in that film we
have a great actress named Hannah John
Comyn
playing a character called the ghost we
also have another villain played by an
awesome actor wall coggan Randall Park
is playing agent Jimmy woo agent ancient
woe is past with O Laurence Fishburne
it's an amazing cast and and we can't
wait to show you more how do you keep
all of these things in your head all the
time I mean these are secrets of someone
they're just crack open your skull and
find out what all these things are how
do you both this is not the Walking Dead
panel no that would be disgusting no but
you but but how do you keep all these
things in your head all the time it's
fun they've been in my head my whole
life so I may as well you know now
you're good job now you get to share
them out last year on stage we saw brie
larson announced as Captain Marvel yeah
yes well uh yeah we're really here we're
really here today to talk about our next
two movies but we thought this would be
cool to see you want to know I'll tell
you something they've been rumors and
I'll tell you those rumors were true
that Nick Fury Sam Jackson is in this
movie and he plays he plays a big part
in it and in this film Nick Fury has two
eyes what because this film takes place
before the events of Iron Man 1 and is
set in the early 1990s and I'll tell you
one other thing for this crowd you might
be crickets in other places but I think
in this crowd the villains of this will
be the first MCU appearance of the
scroll
yeah
we've got we have amazing directors an
abode and rights like working on it hard
and we can't wait to show you more
you